la stratégie que nous sommes pont de la vie est
juste un programme que nous sommes
concevoir pour prévenir le suicide
[Musique]
l'aide est toujours là
aider depuis que nous avons commencé
intervention jusqu'à présent, nous avons
réussi à intervenir dans 31 situations où
dont nous avons réussi à arrêter la tentative
suicide grâce à la participation de
agents métropolitains de contrôle et
aussi l'intervention de notre
psychologues du ministère de la Santé qui
sont là en permanence pour donner
aide et soutien affectif aux
les personnes qui sont comptées dans ce
situation
[Musique]
et nous avons trouvé cet homme que nous avons trouvé
où elle se cachait
précisément pour que l'appareil photo ne
ne l'alertez pas et ne nous dites pas qu'il
c'est là et nous avons pu le faire
intervention alors ce sont aussi des choses
cela arrive et que parfois on ne peut pas
explique très bien comment mais ça arrive
seul
[Musique]
d'anxiété je ne vais pas dans une unité de santé
parce que j'ai honte j'ai peur que
ça va arriver alors il y a une montée
dossier de soins
[Musique]
Bilbao parce que je n'ai que par fréquence Y
un petit n'est jamais moi
ils n'ont suivi aucune fête
[Musique]